The other thing they say is that as people get more affluent,
they have less children than the population decreases as the world's economy
evens out.
And so that we reached like a point where we can maintain a sustainable
population.
How does that still happen without mass genocide or mass sterilization?
That's a good question.
I don't think they're saying that.
And I think what they're saying is that as people become more educated and more
affluent and more successful,
as more urbanization takes place,
people work more and have less children and when they have less children,
the population actually slightly decreases.
This is,
I've heard this argument,
but I don't mind the way fuck more people who fuck more have more children now
that,
that just,
I like,
that's one of those stats where I'd be like,
that might do,
they might just be talking about a particular class of people.
They're still selling 7 billion people.
Yeah.
There's still 7 billion people live mostly for under 22,000 a year.
And it usually,
every time development comes at exploits them.
Yes.
So like where does the balance out of influence coming?
Like I know there's one country now that's doing a universal pay for people,
so are we going to talk about point?
Because when you go to like is does that happen?
Is that,
is that it?
We going to universal pay?
Well,
universal pay would be fine if it was universal effort.
If everybody did it,
put it out the same amount of effort.
I would agree with everyone getting to say no.
I'm not saying I'm for or against that.
I'm just saying how do you maintain,
how does it,
how does it happen that everybody,
all of a sudden it's affluent without mass genocide of sterilization?
I think the idea is that as urban and listen,
this is not my theory for sure,
but I've read it.
The idea is as the world becomes more urbanized and more educated and more
wealthy as as city spread out,
what happens is less of those people have kids and they have less kids.
This is just a a,
that doesn't work.
I don't know if it works or not,
but I know that this is an actual study.
Right.
See if he could find that.
He pulled her vein is fuck,
some people are,
yeah,
most people are.
But the overall humans,
once people have serious careers,
like the man and the woman have a serious career,
they,
both of them are like really invested in their career.
They generally tend to have less kids.
And when this is the idea is that as this people,
I don't know,
it's a solution.
I don't think it's a good solution.
It may become obsessed with work.
That's one of the things where the rest of the world is just not,
that sounds like I'm still talking about America.
Like poor people are fucking man.
So again,
I just goes back to me like I hear those studies show,
but you gotta say to yourself,
how do,
how do you handle the other 4 billion people?
I think the argument is,
and this is not my argument,
where do they go?
They keep,
they keep expanding is that these cities and these urban areas,
uh,
that as the society sort of evens out globally,
whether it takes a thousand years or a hundred years,
as things start to even out,
people will be more like Los Angeles and less,
less,
less like poor place at Calcutta.
Yeah.
But that's site.
But what I'm saying,
it's like poor places of cow cutter.
You've got a bunch of people walking.
It's pumped in this noise.
It could be,
but Los Angeles you've got smaller,
you got traffic,
got stretched really thin.
I'm like there's,
there's,
those are two different extremes that that just seemed weird.
Like I'm just saying,
you know,
sometimes I just feel like maybe we're at the point it ain't no turning around
then we might be.
Yeah.
Just cause we got 7 billion people.
We might be,
but we also might not be.
And I think it's not a bad time to be optimistic because as people look for
better and better solutions.
Yeah,
yeah.
But,
but like jock fresco and the Venus project talks about moneyless society,
the rather radical change of what a political states and things of that nature
Chompsky talks about,
you know,
essentially all all countries essentially now,
no matter western or eastern,
all the Archies and shit.
So like what's the radical departure from this?
Then that saves it all in your mind.
Like where's the Joe Rogan,
United Nations speech?
Reagan was more aware of the flaws of the system than they ever have been any
generation previous.
Okay.
I think when you look at kids from the seventies and eighties I don't think
there were nearly as educated as to how truly fucked up this country is at,
but also yet truly amazing in terms of like the history of the world,
but has plenty to printing to improve on.
But probably will.
I think people are getting better at life to getting better at all,
all of the things and government will come along with it.
I think we're going to get better at things.
We understand each other better.
We communicate better is I'm optimistic and I think with all these incredibly
intelligent people that are looking at the problems in the world,
in terms of carbon,
in the atmosphere or pollution in the ocean,
people are already starting to work on solutions.
I got,
I'm really optimistic that,
that it's,
there's at least the potential for someone to figure out some solutions to some
of these problems.
Overpopulation is always going to be a weird one because you don't have the
right to tell people how many kids they can have,
eh?
Cause who,
like if you meet somebody who's got 10 kids and the most fucking amazing family
ever,
what,
what are you gonna say?
It's bad.
They have 10 amazing kids.
Everybody's great.
You go over the house,
it's all love.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Why is that bad?
You tell it so,
so people are good,
but only a certain amount.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's where it gets weird.
But,
but it's not a cut and dry issue.
It's not a one or a zero.
It's like,
yeah,
there are too many people and yeah,
you probably shouldn't have 10 kids,
but you've got to fucking awesome family,
so,
hey,
have a good night,
man.
What the fuck to do?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You know,
you know,
just speaking as you know,
just that's a lot of the brown people.
This just scenario,
this never worked well for us,
so I'm always,
always,
always check it out.